c'est important pour nous d'avoir
l'occasion de pouvoir
dénoncer ce que mon père a subi encore
deux ans après surtout que depuis notre
passage sur balances ton post qui nous a
permis d'avoir la visibilité sur la
sphère mon père est bas les choses n'ont
pas évolué et pour nous c'est important
le souligner et de le dire haut et fort
et aussi de d'appuyer sur notre message
on défend toujours la paix et
la confiance qu'on a au niveau de la
justice mais par contre on est très
peiné très déçu de notre gouvernement on
sent rejeté aujourd'hui parce que on n'a
pas trouvé
enfin on n'a jamais eu l'occasion
d'être épaulé on la seule fois où on
nous a permis de parler nous comme
superman à on a été humilié et l'on mon
père il a été là et il n'a pas été
respecté donc c'est désolant de savoir
que depuis deux ans une affaire ausssi
aussi triste aussi grave et les faits
parlent d'eux mêmes parce qu'avec toutes
les vidéos qu'on est là qu'on a la
chance d'avoir aujourd'hui est bas les
choses n'ont pas avancé donc c'était
important aujourd'hui de d'en faire part
au français qui nous écoutent qui qui à
chaque fois prennent le temps nous
soutenir et et se demandent eux aussi
bas qu'est ce qui se passe depuis bah
voilà aujourd'hui on vient pour vous
dire rien qui a changé ça fait même
sahara empire lalala est ni le chagrin
qu'on essaie de canaliser en nous et
cette rage d'avoir perdu et d'avoir été
privé notre être aussi cher et bien fait
que d'augmenter et finalement on doit de
plus en plus se taire alors que
finalement on envie d'en parler on à qui
on a envie d'être écouté et on a envie
d'être aidé donc notre place aujourd'hui
on enfin on ici un autre place pour en
parler pour le dénoncer non rien qu'est
ce que vous attendiez après la mort
tragique de votre mari vous attendu un
mois dans un premier temps ge attendait
que le gouvernement prenne ses
responsabilités reconnaissent que ces
quatre individus rapport à tout ce qui
se passait mais je vais pour la terre en
détail sans compter qu'il ya une
instruction en cours
soit suspendue
parce que pour moi voilà le métier de la
police un métier honorable et je pense
que quatre individus comme ça vu long
comporte vu le comportement et le manque
de professionnels et ils ont eu
un tas de choses mais je vais pas trop
m'étaler en fait sûr sûr sûr tout ça
mais je peux juste je peux justifier
tout ce que je suis en train de dire
mais je pense pas que j'aurais le temps
donc c'est pour ça que je vais je vais
faire court donc je pensais qu'avec tous
les faits qu'ils savaient
qu'ils auraient reconnu l'erreur qu'ils
ont fait en fait c'est de faire
confiance à ces quatre individus et leur
donner la chance de porter l'uniforme et
moi pour moi ces quatre personnes elles
sont un guide de représenter la police
la salisse parce qu'un policier est là
pour vous protéger un policier est un
métier pénible il risque sa vie il épate
là pour tuer les gens c'est ça la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui alors
le policier est ce qu'il est là pour
assouvir sa colère on a tous des
problèmes on est tous tendus on a tous
nos soucis mais il faut savoir se
contenir un moment donné il faut savoir
avoir des limites donc certes mon mari
était en colère et non pas son raison
encore une fois je vais perdre et non
pas sans raison mais face à ces
intolérables est impensable de savoir
qui fini étranglé au sol et qui perdent
la vie suite à un contrôle pour moi
c'est pas un dérapage
là dans la main sur la vidéo et rapports
et témoignages qu'on a eu et où on a
compris et on a vu en fait qu'il a
subies n'ont pas juste une clé
d'étranglement qui est censé juste le
ramener au sol voyez ce que je veux dire
pour ensuite le menotter et d'ailleurs
ils ont été formés pour ça et même quand
vous faites une clé d'étranglement vous
êtes censés prendre certaines mesures de
sécurité parce que la vie des gens
allaient elle est sacrée elle a beaucoup
de valeur donc quand vous prenez la
responsabilité et le risque de simple
clé d'étranglement vous êtes censé
mettre la tête en sécurité mais nous on
est loin de tout ça parce que carrément
il a gardé son casque et quand il était
au sol en a continué à l'étrangler c'est
pour ça que nous on parla vient en fait
il pour ça que nous on l'homicide
involontaire l'accident pour nous ces
mots n'ont pas leur place si on étrangle
une personne jusqu'à ce qu'elle rende
l'âme pour nous ce n'est rien d'autre
qu'un qu'un meurtre qu'un homicide
volontaire qui a été commis et face à ça
le gouvernement aurait dû se dire ces
gens sont dangereux ils sont d'une
manière ou d'une autre liées à la mort
de cet homme dans un premier temps dans
l'urgence on va aller retirer des rangs
de la police mais non on les à se
retirer et requalifier leur acte le
symbole c'est donc ça leur fait les
sélects ça il faut laisser le temps de
l'anc est apprécié au juge d'en décider
je joue très bien sur ce plateau vous
disiez que vous aviez confiance dans la
justice avait encore confiance a encore
confiance en la justice instructions et
l'ont france en cours avec d'entente
avec le co vide en plus je pense que ça
n'a pas dû faciliter les choses mais
mais on prend notre mal en patience
parce que la justice a tellement de deux
témoignages de vidéos de ya tellement de
preuves en fait puisqu'ils n'ont pas
fini de toutes les analyses et de toutes
les vérifier pour ensuite faire des
synthèses il ya trop d expertise en fait
qu'ils sont en cours et tout ça ça prend
du temps parce qu'après il ya des tables
rondes qui se font des conclusions qui
sont tirés et tout ça c'est en train de
suivre son cours mais ça met beaucoup de
temps et c'est difficile pour nous de
savoir qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement a
préféré nous donner du dos est carrément
s'y est même allé plus loin que ça
puisqu'on s'est même amusé de nous avec
ce jeu de mots quand j'entends parler de
violences policières j'étouffe mais qui
s'étouffe ont fait c'est tout mais elles
sont réellement go way elles sont
réelles elles sont là mais ce n'est pas
de très bon goût comme la policière
pendant le contrôle qui a dit il faut
bien qu'on s'amuse un petit peu donc
tout le monde s'amuse ma la finale yahia
sommes d'accord
révisé à l'instant votre votre drame
trouve un écho dans l'actualité
immédiate avec cette déclaration choc de
philippe poutou dans l' écoute il a
commencé la police tue évidemment la
police tue hosties 20 ans tu
les canisses murray à marseille pendant
les manifs gilet jaune à une dame qui
est qui fermait ses volets
rémy frais ces quelques années et puis
je crois que faudrait voir les chiffres
précisément mais dans les quartiers
populaires c'est une quinzaine de jeunes
qui sont tués par la police annuellement
donc oui une violence policière
on peut le dire si
la police du doria et sofia sofia est ce
que vous reprendriez votre compte cette
déclaration de philippe poutou oui la
police tue pour moi la police situé sur
elle-même que enfin avec mon expérience
que j'ai vécue après la mort de mon père
quand j'ai vu que le gouvernement en
fait au lieu de nous nous protéger nous
donner des réponses ils à protéger les
criminels et non en fait on s'est sentis
coupables comme si c'était nous les
coupables alors qu'on ait des victimes
donc à partir du moment où on prend le
temps de protéger des criminels c'est
qu'on accepte donc on tolère et en
cautionne que la police je suis bien
mais finalement est-ce qu hier yahia il
ya eu aucune réaction après tout c'est
en fait le truc donc que une fois que le
mal il est arrivé un peu plus rien faire
y'a rien qui nous ramènera cédric certes
mais à un moment donné faut prendre le
temps de se dire oui effectivement on a
un problème et comme pour tout problème
il ya des solutions mais ce problème
faut d'abord le reconnaître plutôt que
s'amuser avec nous et nous dira je
m'étouffe quand j'entends parler de les
chevaux des chiens des phrases toutes
faites comme ça sont pas productives on
n'avance pas en fait donc dit oui
comme le castaner quand il nous a reçus
moi franchement j'ai vu en lui un homme
honorable
respectable il a même dit explicitement
j'ai ma part de responsabilité dans la
mort de monsieur cheveux à cédric parce
que ces gens-là ccpo c'est pour le
peuple qui travaille réellement deux ans
plus tôt est ce que vous croyez encore à
sa sincérité j'avais anton à christophe
castaner bah oui sur le champ parce que
c'était sincère et d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça qu'il n'est pas là il est plus là et
qu'on l'a remplacé en
droit de faire nos déductions
de vous reposer la formule est le risque
et les secondes qui la pousse à lui même
le procès des quatre individus appliquez
vous avez vous avez dit la police tue
comme pout tout en face on a mis du
temps mais ce que j'aime bien et bien
vivant et on est d'accord non non non
c'est pas la question la
sava montre jamais si ça va très loin
lorsque vous ce que c'est très
bien sur internet je ne nie pas que
c'est terrible je
tenais pas que c'est pas terrible de
perdre un père ou de perdre un enfant ou
de perdre à marie bien sûr que c'est
abominable et personne n'aimerait vivre
simple c'est là la russie c'est pas la
question s'est passé c'est pas la
question la question c'est le procès que
vous faites à la police sans aucune
forme
d'oubli de puccini la police turque
zemmour est un amalgame amobee nabeul
encore là excusez moi je me permets je
me permets excusez moi bordeaux il sait
il ce jour ils étaient combien autour de
ce monsieur là 4,4 alors qu'il y en ait
une qui fasse une rente ai aucun danger
qu'est ce qui s'est passé 2 qui va
justifier de tuer savoir-faire et
n'avoir pas ça justifie à la terre
viennent en même temps parce que sachant
qu il y en a il ya une torche que j'ai
pas tenu c'est non assistance à personne
à danger voilà et ça c'est tous ensemble
doit tirer un problème dans la rue
canadien qui qui qui tombe par terre qui
va pas qui va pour mourir ou qui se
blesse on doit intervenir parce que
sinon on risque est là vous avez quatre
policiers le monsieur l'année tous fait
des études non montaner oui peut-être
autoritaire métro
non mais lorsqu'on par
les astronomes viennent à la phrase
messias que mélenchon il ya et vivons
aujourd'hui lyon à la question si vous
aviez cerfs volistes qui suivent on s'en
est pas difficile mais sa
survie il vous plaira tant au monde mais
attend les principales intéressées mais
c'est eux qui vont les prix y est aussi
offrir leurs pairs et amandine est
supporter on se donne la parole à ces
usines qui sont vivants et genre et sap
ce qu'il a voulu intervenir par rapport
à nos propos alors comment vous pouvez
appeler et désigner des individus
après avoir commis une erreur alors on
va pas dire qu'ils ont tués pour vous il
tue pas mais après avoir connu une
erreur comines et repens des
interpellations donc avoir utilisé une
technique d'interpellations qui a tué un
homme se pose comment vous pouvez
appeler ça au moment où ils l'ont tué où
il était sans vie ils ont laissé comme
un déchet sur le bitume on perd au pied
de la tour eiffel 3e léa milite comme
vous pas loin de moi soul est loin de
moi dit excusez moi l'émission que je
pose donc comment vous pouvez appeler
désert dessinée d'individus qui
finalement après avoir commis une erreur
et on va pas employer le mot le terme
tuer mais laissées sans vie loin de main
juste toi et l'indre non j'ai pas trop
comment foot moyen par le tout à terre
et après la seule chose qu'ils ont pensé
au lieu de prendre leurs responsabilités
et de venir en secours de cet homme qui
est mon père qui était au sol sur le
bitume sans vie ils sont mis d'accord
sur une version ils ont pris le temps de
contacter leurs collègues pas pour
appeler les secours en matinée mais
écoutez madame et j'ai écouté l'appel
des gens meurent
contre mer
démontée mais je peux je peux répondre
pour vous écoutez madame loin de moi
l'idée de justifier quelques crimes que
ce soit surtout s'ils proviennent de la
police c'est pas mal du tout ma démarche
ma démarche c'est que un tout la police
ne tue pas 2 2 nous sommes honorés de
nous sommes dans un état de droit où on
n'arrête pas de se mobiliser de
convoquer à tort et à travers l'état de
droit quand il s'agit d'autres problèmes
dans d'autres quartiers là il ya un état
de droit si des erreurs ont été commises
il appartient à la justice aux
inspections compétentes de du ministère
de l'intérieur de déterminer les
responsabilités pendant que mais ils
vont aussi justifiant pen est simple il
faut aussi nous avons une grande cote
lapresa travaillante la police vision de
vous arrêter vous enfuir en faisant des
doigts d'honneur et des bras d'honneur
des bras des
mérites de mourir non j'ai pas dit ça
j'ai dit que dans un an dans un pays
démocratique formant la police circule
intime l'ordre de nous arrêter là et
vous invitez gens mais si celui ci vous
d'essayer de face et on fera plaisir
vous mettez leur un match et un grenache
qui effectivement pas le laisser agir